Speaker 1: Let's hear from a couple of other
people.
Why don't we go next to Colin from Oregon?
Colin, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hi, David.
How are you?
Thank you for having me on the air.
Pleasure.
I have a few.
Oh, yes, thank you.
I have a few questions to ask you, if that's
okay.
Speaker 1: Well, let's see what the first
one is and then we'll evaluate.
Speaker 2: I'm curious about how you feel
about the West Coast's relevance to politics.
Hmm.
Speaker 1: So I. Do you mean just because
with those three left leaning states that
are reliably left leaning at the federal level,
like does it does does it make a difference
what happens in the states?
Is that sort of what you're saying?
Yeah.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
So we hear I know you live on the East Coast
or you know, you're a world traveler.
It's kind of remarkable, in my opinion.
But we talk about a lot Ohio and Iowa and
a lot of these caucuses.
And we decide that these Midwestern states
really decide the the abandoned fold of which
direction the federal court and the federal
government leans.
But the West Coast.
So Gavin Newsom is making all these big appearances.
But the West Coast also made claims saying
like, we're not going to cooperate with these
states that are anti-abortion.
We're not going to cooperate.
Yeah.
What do you think about that?
Speaker 1: I think that the West Coast is
is relevant.
And I have to, you know, no offense to Washington
and Oregon, but California is an absolute
behemoth economically and culturally.
And so, yes, I mean, you've got this state
that is really like a country.
It's got a larger population and a larger
land area than many countries around the world.
Running the state of California is a bigger
job than running many countries, and that
is of massive and significant importance.
And so I do think that in particular, California,
I'm not I'm not putting down Washington and
Oregon, but it's such a behemoth that it is
an economic leader.
It is a cultural leader.
It is also a media leader.
And so I think it's of massive consequence
and impact.
Speaker 2: So you think that.
My next question is, do you really follow
Western politics closely or is it kind of
on your side sites like okay, I'll check that
every once in a while.
Or is it really important to, you.
Speaker 1: Know, listen, I mean, I don't follow
the internal politics of Oregon any more or
less than I follow the internal politics of
Indiana.
Even though it's further away from me, I'm
not following it less or more.
It's just I think people in my position, we
tend to follow what's going on locally to
us.
And then the big flash points and certainly
Florida and California are two of those and
then people that are kind of living lives.
So but but it's there's no particular reason
I'm not following Oregon politics.
It's just I'm also not following North Dakota
politics or Michigan politics.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
I just respect your opinion.
And you're a political person.
And Oregon's politics and Washington politics.
We if you haven't noticed, we kind of the
governors came together and said we are not
going to cooperate with states that are going
to persecute people that come to our states
to seek abortions.
Yes.
Do you think that's going to strike some political
strife?
Is that going to cause some civil divide?
Speaker 1: It is.
And we're seeing it because there are states
already thinking about responding to that
by saying we are going to criminal criminalize
anybody who helps someone go to another state
for an abortion that may be legal there.
So that is becoming a fight.
Speaker 2: It's really unfortunate.
That's all I have to say.
All right.
Thank you for your time.
Speaker 1: Colin from Oregon, thank you so
much for the call.
Many good calls today.
Many, I think, is the right way to say it.
I appreciate everyone who called in.
I can't speak to anyone else today, but I
will speak to more people very, very soon.
Quick break and back after this